[موسيقى]
تويتر
لخريف شتاء هذا العام قدم البريطاني
مجموعته الجديده المتعوره حول احياء
الماضي
في الحيويه التي سعى اليها وحققها عندما
كان يبلغ من العمر واحدا 21 عاما ليكون
اصغر مصمم ازياء في التاريخ مجموعه شبيهه
بقصيده وهو المكان الذي يلتقي فيه العالم
القديم بعالم جديد دائما
65 عاما وتحديدا في الثلاثين من يناير من
عام
1958 قدم انسان مجموعته الاولى
وبالتالي شهد عالم الموضه تغيرا ملحوضا
مره اخرى وفي تلك المجموعه لربيع والص
1958 التي استمد الوحي منها بشكل اساسي
لعرض جونز هذا العام يعانق التاريخ الرجال
المزيج ما بين الطابع الذكوري والانثوي
وتلتقي تقاليد مواد الخياطه البريطانيه مع
تلك الخاصه بمصمم الازياء الراقيه الناس
الحركه والحداثه والطابع العملي والثلاثه
واعتماد البساطه والانسيابيه بعيدا عن كل
ما هو مبالغ فيه والتوجه نحو مزيج بين
الاسسبين الرسمي وغير الرسمي في الملابس
الشخصيه بدات تجاريه في مجموعه ديور
الرجاليه الجديده في حين تتحول الملابس
الى قطع هجينه وتخضع للتحويلات وتغيرات
ليقوم كل شخص بارتدائعها على طريقتها
الخاصه يتغلغل الطابق السهل والمبسط في كل
تفصيل حامل في تياته الدقه والصعوبه في
مجموعه لا تعكس اي دلاله على التقييد في
عمليه حياكتها
[موسيقى]
شيء مختلف وجميل مجموعه
جدا عراقي وكل الاقمشه
اللي يستخدموها من باب الصيفيه من اجود
انواع وفيها اتن
تفاصيل بالضبط
يتحول الى قميص صيادين فضفاض طويل وتتكيف
خياطه تصميم اكاسيا ذات الاسلوب الكاشف
للكتفين مع طابع اللامبالان مسترخيه
لابتكار بدله رجاليه من الصوف كجزء من
قامه والطقم الجديده اما معطفو باسباغ 2
بقصته لياقه الفضفاضه اصبح الان مغمورا
بتويد بدون جار الجديد مع اضافه اكمام
مفتوحه وزوده بصحه الاحذيه والجسمات
المطبوعه بالتقنيه الثلاثيه الابعاد فضلا
عن الملابس العمليه النموذجيه الخاصه
بالسفر عبر البحار شوهدت على منصه العرض
وترتكز الحقائب بشكل اساسي على مبدا
الرصانه والاناقه والدقه وقد تم تجدها من
العناصر الدخيله مع اعتماد تصميما خارجي
فائق الامان
سكيبيدي
[موسيقى]
عميله
معظم الرجال